eleven days after the deadly camp fire
that started in Northern California we
are beginning to understand how it may
have begun California's largest Power
Company that specific gas and electric
is under new pressure to explain its
actions before the fire that fire by the
way is now blamed for 77 deaths and that
number is likely to rise nearly 1,000
people are still officially unaccounted
for the Wildfire has burned 150 thousand
acres or about 235 square miles it's
destroyed more than ten thousand six
hundred homes
officials say the campfire is now 65
percent contained Meg Oliver is in
Paradise California the town that was
nearly destroyed the day this fire began
Meg good morning beyond a good morning
before the fire tore through this
community PG&E said it might turn off
the power as a precaution because of
high fire danger now many are wondering
why the utility kept the electricity
going and whether it played a role in
what's now the deadliest wildfire in
state history Pacific Gas and Electric
has confirmed it had two powerline
failures the day the deadly campfire
started the first one occurred at 6:15
a.m. less than 10 miles from paradise
just 18 minutes before the flames
erupted nearby now the utility company
says another power outage happened at
6:45 a.m. about five miles away in con
cow the same town being investigated as
a possible second location where the
fire started
[Applause]
while PG me reported the first outage
that same day it waited more than a week
to tell state regulators about the
second one in a statement the company
says as more information became
available about this location we
determined it was important to share
that information what I left I could
hear the fire behind me jo-ann Schaefer
says days before the fire destroyed her
home PG&E called her and sent her an
email like this one saying they might
shut off her power as a precaution but
she says the electricity was still on
when she was forced to flee are you
wondering why they didn't turn it off
I'm very wondering why I'm wondering why
this whole thing happened in a statement
the utility says in determining a
public-safety power shut off it
considers multiple factors including
strong winds very low humidity levels
critically dry vegetation and on the
ground observations the forecasted
conditions didn't meet the criteria the
cause of the fire is still under
investigation as officials tried to
account for a hundred still on a list of
those reported missing we're hopeful
that we're going to ultimately be able
to account for the vast majority of
those individuals and it's it's a
process officials here are using rapid
DNA test kits to help identify the
remains still an anthropologist working
with the forensic effort tell CBS News
that positive identification may be
impossible for some and other remains
may never be recovered at all we're
standing in front of this general store
biana as you can see everything burned
to a crisp and that is the scene for
miles
it just looks like a war zone meg thank
you so much important to note that
authorities don't expect full
containment until November 30th in a
reminder to you to see the names of
those still unaccounted for in the
campfire you can go to CBS this morning
calm